what's your the one constant you look
back and say that was the most amazing
thing I've ever been a part of that one
concert the Apollo Theater with Eddie
Kendrick and David Ruffin when we
brought Eddie and David out and reprise
The Temptations uh medley uh that we you
know Daryl and I were both Temptations
fans Daryl was actually friends with the
original group and when I first met
there one of the first things we did was
we went to New York City and we went to
the Apollo Theater and we hung out in
the dressing room with the Temptations
this was probably 68 or 67 and we
um we sat in the front row and watched
The Temptations at the Apollo Theater
the original group with Eddie Kendrick
David Ruffin you know Paul Williams and
you know Melvin and Franklin and Otis
Williams
um and uh
so then we were asked to reopen the
Apollo after it had been renovated
and it was a big deal to to play the
Apollo um and so we asked Eddie and
Eddie and David if they'd come and sing
those songs with us and we were on stage
we did the steps we did the choreography
and it was like honestly it was like
tripping I I thought it was like I could
see myself from above it was like I was
not I was and you know people talk about
out of body experience it sounds oh
hippy-dippy and everything right
honestly it was an actual out of body
experience I I remember almost as if I
was looking at my doing it in real time